What populations as a whole, you
know, when you look at the world, um,
what, where are the people
living the longest and why? Well,
it's debatable.
There are these blue zones.
I think many of your listeners
will have heard about those. Um,
but there are pockets
that have great genes, um,
but they also have great diets
and lifestyles. And so the,
the best one that I'm familiar with
is the island of Okinawa in Japan.
And, uh, and by the way, I used
to follow the [inaudible] diet.
A couple of my good friends
wrote a book about it,
so I was on Tofu when some fish felt
really great. Couldn't keep it up,
but those why couldn't you keep it up?
I had kids and our meals turned into
pizzas and pastor. Yeah, unfortunately.
But, uh, I'm getting back there
now that my kids are teenagers,
but the Okinawans date,
they live into their hundreds,
uh, fairly frequently.
It's not one in a million.
It's more like one and I think 100,000
or something. So it's 10 times higher.
They, they work most of their
lives. They're physically active.
They fast a lot.
And they have a lot of green
leafy vegetables and that
seems to be the secret.
And there's, uh, there were,
there, there were selling some,
there was something about their mineral
rich diet they remembered they were
selling. It was like a big thing
for a while. Coral calcium.
And they were using that as an example
of why the Okinawans were living so long.
Do you remember that kind
of do remember add? Yeah,
but in scientific circles we weren't
really bothered with it. Yeah.
Like there's calcium is
calcium, right? Yeah.
I don't know how much better it better
calcium from coral or something. I mean,
it might be wrong about that,
but I just remember reading about the
Okinawans and the, the speculation.
They seaweed as well. Right?
They are very healthy.
Probably the best thing that
they do is they don't overeat.
Stop at 70%. Yeah, I'm a glutton.
That's my number one problem. I just
love to eat. Yeah. Yeah, me too.
And I keep going once I'm in it and I
just want to just keep shoving it in my
face.
But I've done a good job over the last
few years of tapering that off and the
intermittent fast and I think is probably
one of the best things I've ever done
in terms of, you know, just maintaining
energy levels, maintaining body weight,
that kind of stuff. Yeah.
Yeah. You look good.
So I think that that's one of the
best things that people can do.
What we've known for 70 or more years
actually is if you calorie restrict
animals actually even eat cells and words,
they live longer.
And this is the most robust way to,
to prevent cancer, heart disease,
Alzheimer's in a mouse.
Um,
and so the intimate and fasting is
just a way of mimicking this calorie
restricted diet. So what,
what is calorie restriction?
It's reducing what you would,
your doctor would recommend for your body,
but reducing it packed about 20 to 30%.
So it's quite extreme.
That's not pleasant. I tried that
for a week, gave up too hard,
but intimate and fasting like yourself,
it's doable. It's not always pleasant,
but uh, I think that's the best
way to do it. And with the mice,
it works just as well
as calorie restriction,
which is pretty much always
being a bit hungry. Now,
what other things are you looking at in
terms of mitigating stress or like what
other factors are there that you,
that you have to keep an eye on? Yeah,
stress is a bad one. Um, I try to, uh,
take life in my stride, not
get too worried about it.
Remember what's important.
So my heart rate rarely goes up.
Um,
even under really extreme circumstance.